move your right hand forward
you took
you took two steps
start over get that
you did it again you're taking two steps
it's bushido tencon you shift your
weight
and you go back
shift
not possible
it's midfoot pivot
you have to bring that foot in otherwise
there's no bait
you have to bring that foot in you're
not in on me you've been false on me
come on
you whoa
to breathe out you're holding your
breath
switch
you have a lot of face tension
you're not in false humming
you're almost in come on
incorrect start over
lose the face tension lose stop go back
you have eye tension
release release
what what you're doing now
is no different from anything
pleasurable you would do
okay so if you don't eat like that drive
like that
uh kiss like that don't do it here okay
you get rid of the face tension
except
so you have to bring that foot in you
keep forgetting the right foot has to be
brought in
go ahead and go nope
go
and so did you hit her center
yeah because you're too you're out of
range
you're just hitting her hands
bring that foot in
i am
okay so you have the wrong range for
even touching
face tension eye tension eye tension
don't bounce
you settle
don't look with your eyes don't look
with your eyes
state
you're on the line
clear the line clear the line
yes
come on
okay but now you have that weird angle
so
stay there
for this angle
this sword needs to be over here that's
where your center is so you're over
rotating
this this foot ankle this is where my
sword goes okay then they go over here
slide pick it up
pick up the end
okay
like you know what's right
always under your hips always
under your hip under your foot
now i go
shift
turn on that mid foot turn on
turn on the middle
and you're gonna clear that one
boom
okay
okay where's your neck where'd your neck
go
put your shoulders down
pull your shoulders down you're freaking
out
again
don't run from it
she moves your sword you don't move your
sword she moves your sword
[Applause]
what's missing on martha
she's gonna touch my sword pull right
here
i already have that food stuck on her
same feeling
when we stop at saigon
stuck you see you feel that stuff not
hair loose like stuck right now okay
so when she goes up
you're already right there you see can
you feel it
that
adhesion break
in
then i get it again
okay
it's not running away
it's not being knocked out
it's the same ikey adhesion just from
luke's side okay
you have a deflecting angle
you want a displacing angle
[Applause]
okay i'll show you what i mean
to knock her down
her sword this is not
the place where i hit her sword
in in the live version
it's not it this is a
training vector
okay where i can work
on
just the cookie static version
you can work on the intensity okay got
in
well i'm not i don't want to knock her
sword out of the way
because then i'm going to try to knock
her sword out of the way in the dynamic
version but that's not what you do you
displace her sword
okay
you try to take
a means the slightest angle of incidence
towards that thing and you're going to
miss her sword okay
so
she's here
and you're going to make contact very
much like the first segment first
segment boom very much like that
you're here you're going to make contact
with her sword
stuck again stuck again okay stuck again
do you feel that stuck again and he goes
boom straight down
okay
contact
and then
[Applause]
is
and try to not deflect it
chest out chest out you look very
worried start over start over
that can't be your mindset
this is as easy as it's gonna get isn't
it
okay so this can't be freaking us out
get that foot off the line
not too much you're gonna lose your your
uh
the atoshi you're gonna use lose the
atoshi alignment
you know bring that foot in more and
bring that back foot in more and to your
right under your right hip
and you turn on that right
mid midfoot vector don't travel in space
and double pivot
because you're going to do that huge
sweeping thing
turn right there in space
whoa gotta breathe out
try it again
if it's too far left
you're all you're not you're your arches
are all weird
straighten your ankles
ankles come straight out of the foot
breathe you're still not breathing
hey
cochlear literally means breath but it's
a pre-modern understanding so it doesn't
just mean breath okay but if you're not
breathing then you're not doing cookie
you're not doing it okay you get it so a
lot of times people key eye but the
whole point of key is that you're not
all you're not doing
uh some choreographing ki you're not
doing that okay ki you shouldn't have a
two-syllable ki
okay do you understand there's no two
syllable key eyes and you don't say key
i that's like on the bathroom going
that's not what you do okay it's just
release release okay uh so we're coming
out
and everything releases
inhale
don't get ahead of me
pillow
fill the space
with that release of
key
i want you to look how slow my sword is
moving through space
it's going really slow get in
you're out of range
you can't train in fear
cannot train in here
training here is not training
okay
you hear expel out everything if you
want to make a louder
ki go ahead
but at least that
don't hold your bruh okay
good good contact
good use of the vector
release the throat fill with air press
your eyes
out
good
keep your chest out okay don't hunt your
butt
release the throat the body will feel
over there and pressurize the tandem
okay
good
let all the energy go at the bottom you
get up about i don't know a second too
early
take your time
single mind try it again
single mind
not two thoughts not two breaths
not two sounds
not to cut
nope try it again mind is stuttering do
it again
so you rush in your mind right now
there's no uh there's no part time okay
so you don't have to start right when
she does her cut
you can hang out there till you get
yourself in a single-mindedness okay try
it again
you don't have to do it right away
don't shoot on the buzzer
wait wait wait wait wait
that's all right we're gonna do it again
wait wait
stop bridging your cuts too high go back
better let's do it again from there
single mind single breath single cut
wait virginia it's one inch off the
wrist
better
let's do it from the start
fix yourself
no
one thing
now
keep going
don't bounce at the end
it's one settled
are you going to kia
[Applause]
he i
come on man
okay so here it is in my book i
demonstrated it this is the third class
on it i demonstrated it i
pointed it out once i pointed it out
twice
right
and then i told you twice and you still
didn't do it okay
so now you're untrainable
got it
make yourself trainable otherwise
there's no point to being here so you
have to risk it maybe it feels
uncomfortable maybe it's not you
you're not here to be you right you're
here to be a new you so get that key i
going maybe you need to make a sound get
that thing out because you look like
you're suffocating out there okay try it
again don't be you you're here not to be
you let's go
make this your life or death rep i gotta
do it this one i gotta do it
is gonna do it
well you tried right
keep trying until you get it
so
okay that was a good contact what's the
destination though
for centers
don't change the words
you're in the hands
hey
brilliantly
okay so here i'm going to uh don't do
anything stay where you are stay where
you are because stay where you got it
stay where you are here i'm going to
pull
and you're pulling on your shoulder and
eventually i pull you see that
okay well
here i'm going to go right into the
center do you see so not pulling this
until it catches up to your center fool
right here into the center you see that
difference okay so same thing not
pulling here
right
into the center into the center see in
the second in this section
do you see that okay
so
i have the same thing
it's not that i'm cutting down on this
and eventually it checks you
you see sort is going down and then it
pulls on your shoulders and then it gets
your center
right where i'm touching
right into your body in your body
you see
so don't go here
it's going to hurt your hands it's bad
it can't be
make contact
right there
and that this goes not on the top down
into your hand
into your body feel that
okay
[Music]
you see that difference
there's you
here's me
okay do you see that difference okay
let's try it again